noël marti la grasse mat et bijoux ses
chiens
plus jamais nui la grande sera autour du
cou des sceaux
alain qui va
que la grandeur
ce serait tanner
on dit ça
il y en a qui marmonne
serais tu as là
et ça c'est de toute la semaine on ne la
voit plus
a dit ça
on peut la retrouver rue d'hesdin
les graves
ce week-end
en complet veston la décoration a vendu
lui seul
avec les dieux de bois
les gardiens de mardi
à voir
mais ses bisous chasse
autour du pot
maintenant
bien un qui raconte que dans sa famille
quand on se maquille
rien qui raconte
sa famille
on a parfois hauteur lorsque ce maquis
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu